effettivamente è stato molto difficile
spiegare a mia madre perché da un anno a
questa parte e mi sono trasferito a
vivere in un piccolo paese vicino
brindisi
io lavoravo per la regione puglia per un
programma molto noto ed ero come dire il
mito di mia madre no perché avevo una
cosa che assomigliava un posto fisso ea
un certo punto abbiamo deciso di fare
una cosa strana e ovvero provare a
immaginare che in un piccolo paese
dell'alto salento cioè lontano dei
flussi principali di persone e di cose
era possibile innestare un progetto di
sviluppo locale che facesse leva sulla
riqualificazione del più grande immobile
di archeologia industriale di tutta
l'area della provincia di brindisi e si
chiama ora ex fatta e dello stabilimento
che vedete le vostre spalle in quel
simpatico vecchietto che è raffigurato
in fotografia e il mio predecessore
lui è l'ammiraglio fatta è stato
l'ultimo gestore dello stabilimento
enologico quando ancora produceva vino
fino alla metà degli anni sessanta
marito di di alta dentice di frasso che
era la ultima erede di una famiglia
nobile che era proprietaria di
praticamente terreni opifici grandi
strutture nell'area dell'alto salento
4mila metri quadri oltre un ettaro di
terreno e uno stabile in condizioni di
abbandono completamente inagibile del
quale provare a fare qualche cosa
la storia di questo stabile potrebbe
raccontare la storia dello sperpero
delle risorse pubbliche nelle regioni
del mezzogiorno d'italia milioni di euro
investiti per riqualificare ora le
fondamenta ora le coperture ora
ipotetici progetti per
un osservatorio regionale sulla
mitologia che hanno fatto in modo che
questo spazio fosse stato è chiuso per
oltre 50 anni circondato da una grande
lamiera per cui passandoci all'esterno
tu che devi solamente lo skyline dei
tetti ed è il classico posto dove le
mamme dicevano i bambini di non andare a
giocarci no perché era un posto
pericoloso ora occupato dai senza casa
ora discarica abusiva ora ricovero per i
mezzi della nettezza urbana
ovviamente i bambini ci andavano a
giocare e questo ha rappresentato un
enorme contenitore di energia per tanti
siamo entrati in questo spazio
abbiamo detto ok ce la vediamo noi
mino e gionata sono due dei protagonisti
del progetto di autocostruzione che oggi
vi racconterò attraverso il quale
abbiamo deciso di sostituire la pratica
ordinaria di edilizia attraverso cui si
recupera un immobile abbandonato per
mettere al lavoro operatori volontari e
provare a restituire al territorio
regionale un grande spazio per
l'aggregazione per l'innovazione sociale
e per la creatività da dove siamo
partiti e non esiste progetto di
sviluppo locale non esiste impresa e non
esiste neanche immobile recuperato che
possa funzionare senza una comunità di
persone e di progetti e quando ancora lo
spazio era inagibile al 70 per cento ed
era un grande cantiere del quale non
sapevamo il futuro abbiamo aperto le
porte abbiamo cominciato a dire alle
persone
venite a visitare questo spazio ea
immaginare di innestare la vostra
attività progettuale all'interno di
queste mura la nostra prerogativa è
avere un approccio dal basso è un luogo
comune ovviamente ma che cosa vuol dire
provare a riuscire a tenere insieme
all'interno dello stesso spazio è
un'associazione di donne che si occupa
di artigianato è una comunità di
sviluppatori di app un gruppo di ragazzi
che esaltano come ninja perché fanno
parkour e insieme musicisti di ritorno
ho studiato nei migliori conservatori
d'italia provano a tornare in puglia per
poter realizzare la loro impresa
quindi prima regola una comunità di
persone progetti è un elemento
indispensabile per poter pensare di far
rivivere un posto abbandonato risorse
poche e relazioni molte questo è un
progetto che punta a dimostrare che è
possibile generare più valore delle
risorse che vengono investite al proprio
interno ma relazioni molte che cosa vuol
dire questo che oltre che a puntare
sulla comunità di oltre 35 gruppi tra
associazioni e gruppi informali giovani
imprese collettivi che vivono la
struttura abbiamo cominciato a sondare
il territorio intorno a noi ea capire
come quello che gli altri consideravano
uno scarto nel nostro processo di
autocostruzione potesse diventare per
noi una risorsa
la fiera del levante che probabilmente
in puglia il più grande ente allestitore
insomma di organizzatore di eventi al
termine della settimana che
l'appuntamento per eccellenza di
finestrati di tutti i pugliesi
conferisce in discarica oltre l'ottanta
per cento del materiale che viene
comunemente utilizzato dalle società di
allestimento per realizzare gli stand i
capannoni padiglioni e così via
attraverso il cantiere di
autocostruzione abbiamo provato a
dimostrare che è possibile realizzare
una relazione sistematica tra
recuperatori ovvero persone che hanno
bisogno di materiale per riqualificare
spazi e imprese che sostengono dei costi
per smaltire in discarica ai rifiuti
prodotti dalla loro attività ordinaria
attraverso questo progetto per una
società di allestimento è più
conveniente smaltire in discarica
piuttosto che stoccare quintali
tonnellate di legname teli in pvc
parquet anche materiale pregiato molte
relazioni sono un'ottima strategia per
portare avanti un progetto di sviluppo
locale e poi abbiamo bisogno di capi
cantiere perché il lavoro volontario e
un
lavoro che va organizzato valeria e
angelica sono due designer entrambi
pugliesi un'asta a milano ecc ha un
collettivo che si chiama controprogetto
loro lavorano sul re cycle design
l'altra e angelica è una designer st san
vito dei normanni lavora sul tema della
domesticità anno insieme ad altri
designer e architetti in residenza per
50 giorni all'interno dello spazio
condotto un'attività di partecipazione
che ha coinvolto oltre 100 ragazzi
sapete quelle persone che si sente dire
al telegiornale i ragazzi che né
studiano né lavorano
beh i nostri paesi sono pieni di queste
persone
io credo che non sia semplicemente un
tema di sistema sociale ed economico
penso che se anche un tema di relazioni
e di meccanismi di opportunità che il
territorio in grado di generare oltre
100 volontari che sono stati guidati
attraverso un cantiere di
autocostruzione ai quali sono stati
trasmessi conoscenze che oggi permettono
di vivere lo spazio dell'ex fatta come
uno spazio dove è possibile immaginare
di creare impresa creativa e poi un
grande ragionamento tra formale
informale legale e illegale pubblico
privato e l'ex sede uno spazio pubblico
però gestito da una società privata che
la società per cui lavoro ma che cosa si
intende per spazio privato quando
proponi alla tua comunità di riferimento
di sostenere lo spazio ciascuno secondo
le proprie possibilità ovvero immaginare
un impresa culturale in cui i tuoi
clienti che smettono di essere clienti
ovviamente contribuiscono la tua
sostenibilità economica ciascuno
attraverso un sistema di autovalutazione
del peso dell'occupazione del proprio
tempo del proprio spazio all'interno
della struttura oppure 80 metri quadri
della struttura sono ancora dal punto di
vista formale inagibili per quanto
vengano utilizzati
non è un mistero la grande maggior parte
la maggior parte degli spazi pubblici
per la cultura al mezzogiorno sono spazi
che non rispettano il sistema di vincoli
attraverso cui vengono costruiti i
meccanismi di autorizzazione e così via
ma che cos'è il legale tenere uno spazio
importantissimo dal punto di vista
storico e sociale abbandonato
all'interno di un territorio oppure
provare a forzare il concetto di
legalità per restituire un luogo
pubblico alla comunità
e questi sono alcuni risultati del
nostro cantiere di autocostruzione una
sala prove dove dei tecnici del suono
del territorio stanno immaginando di
costruire la loro impresa costruita
attraverso una sperimentazione
attraverso l'impiego di paglia come
materiale fonoassorbente e un mandala
per un laboratorio di giovani psicologhe
che realizzano attività all'interno
dell'ex fatta interamente costruito con
moquette di recupero destinata al macero
o ancora un'area palestra che ospita
attività legate alle arti marziali al
parkour alla danza al teatro e poi
questo grande elemento simbolico che
abbiamo voluto realizzare come landmark
di questo progetto una grande goccia di
materiale di recupero recuperato da un
raccoglitore di legna anche qui formale
informale che nel proprio terreno ha
costruito un centro di recupero
attraverso cui le persone della
provincia di brindisi conferiscono
legname e che le utilizza per il proprio
termo camino e per le necessità di una
rete di auto costruttori che è al di
fuori dei circoli ufficiali della
costruzione già esiste sul nostro
territorio
se ci venite a trovare ci sarà un pezzo
di legno anche per voi